and so we've been talking about the
prospects over deal it feels like we're
in a very different position than last
week it does Phyllis they're more
optimistic noises coming through is
there any chance that the Lib Dems could
back that deal if it was for example put
to a referendum like Liberal Democrats
will always vote for amendments in
support of a people's vote we've been
back here people's vote for the last
three or so years and and we think that
that is the best way for the public to
have the final say on what happens next
with brexit but let's be clear what
we're looking at here this deal
obviously details to be confirmed but it
looks like very much the free trade
agreement type proposal that was put
forward in November 2018 that the
government's own analysis showed would
be catastrophic that it would be worse
than the financial crash in terms of the
contraction in the economy you know that
is not something that any government
should be responsibly putting forward on
a voluntary basis let's just I just want
to just really try and nail you down on
the beginning of your answer here are
you saying then if for example the deal
was going to be put to a complimentary
referendum you could back that next week
in the comments so we will always
support an amendment that says that
there should be a people's vote I've not
heard anything from the prime minister
that suggests that that is what he would
do but we should look at the inductive
votes from March where 280 MPs did back
of people's vote so ultimately we want a
deal to be put to the public so there
you can have the final say and Liberal
Democrats will campaign strongly to
remain because we believe that or there
is no possible deal that we could get
that is better than the deal that we
have as members of the European Union
and the public need to have the choice
to decide whether or not they wants this
ridiculous deal that Boris is cooking up
or indeed trees amazed do you haven't
only what details that you have wait
don't you call it it's ridiculous but I
mean it does it does look like it's
going to be a very hard break set for at
least GB possibly with some changes in
Northern Ireland but that's gonna cost
jobs it's going to be problematic for
our NHS we've already got 5,000 nurses
from the EU
lost from our NHS a time when there are
nursing shortages that is having a real
impact already on our NHS Jeremy Corbyn
in my nephew earlier said he would
caution MPs
against backing a complimentary
referendum so is he wrong then well I
mean Jeremy Corbyn is all over the place
so yes
typically he's typically he's wrong but
he I mean it his his party are wanting
to negotiate breaks that they want to
get a break that deal and what we want
is to stop breaks that we think that
it's going to be bad for our country for
jobs for public service he's back a
second referendum well I mean apparently
you know we'll we'll see I mean
certainly there's been some Labour MPs
who have not done so so you know they
say that they're backing that but let's
look at there let's look at their
actions I mean Jeremy Corbyn was calling
for article 52 be triggered the day
after the referendum
you know he's somebody who have said
that he wants to deliver a breaks there
and it doesn't matter if you put a red
rosette on it or a blue rosette on it
breaks it is still going to be bad for
our country let's look at the Lib Dems
position shall we and because you've
said that if you win power which I
accept is perhaps a at all ask at the
next election you would want to revoke
article 50 how can you really have
Democrats in your party name if you want
to overturn the result of the referendum
without even putting it back to the
people well as I've just said we want to
put this back to the people through a
people's vote you've thought you want to
revert
but if it so happens that there isn't a
referendum on a brexit deal and instead
we are in a general election scenario
then we think that the public need to
have the ability to choose that they
want to stop breaks it in such a general
election and as Liberal Democrats we
will give them that choice by saying if
you elect a Liberal Democrat government
then we will revoke article 50 and if
people democratically choose to elect a
Liberal Democrat government in that
scenario then I think people will then
expect us to revoke article 50 which is
exactly what we will do and we were
talking about earlier about what will
happen if a deal is brought back if it
isn't brought back by the end of the
week according to the ban Act
Boris Johnson needs to request an
extension if he doesn't do that they may
then be a
confidence vote in his leadership and
interim Prime Minister coming forward to
request an extension Jeremy Corbyn says
that should be him he's right isn't
easily during the opposition why weren't
you back him well he doesn't have the
numbers which I understand is because of
you well it's not actually I mean if you
add up if you add up the numbers even
without the Liberal Democrats he's far
short of it and let's remember why he is
far short part of that is because there
are people who where Labour MPs who have
left the Labour Party because of their
failure to deal with anti-semitism you
know we're not talking about you know
something that is you know irrelevant or
or minor we're talking about something
which is about the fundamental value of
whether people are treated with equality
so you know there's very good reasons
people have for saying that they want
back Jeremy Corbyn and I think we need
to find in those circumstances a
solution that works and I think there's
a wide range of people like who'd lead
such a government I put forward the
ideas of Ken Clark or Harriet Harman but
if you look at others who have been long
respected MPs there's people like
Margaret Beckett I mean you know there's
lots of people who are that little bit
above party politics who could in an
emergency scenario step in and we need
to have that as an insurance option but
let's remember Boris Johnson should obey
the law and he is now given an
undertaking to a court that he will send
that letter so I think that the way in
which MPs were able to work together
cross party to pass that legislation to
try to remove the threat of New Deal was
a very important piece of cross party
working there could be an election
sooner rather than later and that
election could very well produce the
hung parliament if the polls are right
there any circumstances that you would
back a Jeremy Corbyn government no
Jeremy Corbyn is not fit to be Prime
Minister Boris Johnson is not fit to be
Prime Minister and the country deserves
a better choice than either of those two
so Julian why should anyone vote for you
if you're just saying that we're not
going to get involved in any of it we
won't support this will wait supporting
this person what is the point of the
Liberal Democrat the point of the
Liberal Democrats is to make sure that
people can vote for a party that will
stop brexit and then go about
transforming our country making a
economy fairer
tackling the climate emergency
to actually be able to have a country
that people can enjoy and have good
quality of life at the moment brexit is
sucking the life out of our politics it
is something which is going to holler
economy and our public services we need
we've really clear on them matter and
the reason that it's given us a boost is
that there are millions of people out
there in the country who are in despair
of this prospect of leaving the European
Union whether that's the people who are
worried about their friends and
neighbors who are you citizens from the
other 27 countries whether that's people
who are worried about their jobs whether
that's people just see that we should be
an open and fair and inclusive country
and we should be working with other
countries to solve our shared problems
rather than pulling up the drawbridge so
what would be a good night for the
Liberal Democrats a direction electing a
Liberal Democrat majority government
with me as Prime Minister and what do
you think the odds are that are really I
think I think it's entirely possible
we're in a very volatile time in our
politics as I say there are people who
have left the Labour Party people who
have left the Conservative Party as MPs
and indeed as members and as voters we
beat both the conservative and labour
parties at the European elections the
Liberal Democrats different a general
election though isn't it well it is you
and I know that of course it is but
these are volatile times in politics and
the reason that there's a big change is
that the fault line is shifted it's not
about left-right anymore it is that
fundamental difference about whether
it's standing up for liberal values
against authoritarianism whether your
approach is an open one or a closed one
and the Liberal Democrats are firmly on
one side of that divide and both the
Conservatives and labor parties are
struggling because they are divided are
you expecting more defections I'm always
hopeful I speak with lots of MPs who are
unhappy in their current parties and of
course it's a very personal decision a
personal journey for people to make so
we were delighted to welcome Heidi Allen
to the Liberal Democrats just a few said
that though more conservatives who could
be coming away she right or is that a
little bit optimistic well now I'm not
going to go into the details of private
conversations you'll understand that but
I mean I would certainly say I'm
still having conversations and indeed
people in the labour party are very
unhappy too for not just the reasons
that I mentioned about
Korman's inability to tackle
anti-semitism but also their failure on
brakes it you know the biggest issue of
the day where the leader of the
Opposition can't even stand up for the
national interests and say that we
should stop brexit he does have to be
fair they are now saying that they want
to see a reference I mean that is a
clear position there's no he's been
dragged kicking and screaming to that
position and he still won't say what
side he would campaign on in such a
referendum because ultimately he wants
breaks it to happen I can't see any
other explanation for it well I've got
you just want ask you one more question
off the back of that Jeremy Corbyn
interview because I asked him about
whether or not if there was a hung
apartment and the SNP were asking for a
second independence referendum if that
is something that he could countenance
is a price of getting into number 10 he
said it's not something they would be
doing at the beginning is that something
that alarm should be answer that you
heard well of course and it will alarm
millions of people in Scotland who want
to keep Scotland in the United Kingdom
and it to keep the United Kingdom in the
European Union that is the Liberal
Democrats that are standing up for
Scotland's place in the UK and the UK's
place in the EU we should we should
recognise the value of working across
the UK family of nations and across the
European Union and instead of having all
of this constitutional wrangling we can
make that stop and get on with making
people's lives better ok Jay Swenson
thank you very much for coming on the
program today